that's right it's trash tuesday welcome
you guys today is the episode where we
all get canceled or we're extreme
feminist icons i really don't know which
one
um i have road dates coming up i'm so
excited my stand-up shows are going to
be very personal and you're going to
learn way too much about me and
hopefully you'll have a fun time i know
you will um you can get tickets at
esteronice.com i'm coming to san
francisco portland and new york and
some of those might already be sold out
i'm thank you so much for your support i
can't wait and sleepoverbyaster.com for
my wonderful new items it's me annie
letterman i know you can't tell because
i look so hot you don't even know what
to do with your nether regions because i
look so gorgeous today
anyway it's the halloween episode you
can come see me
live in philadelphia my hometown at the
punch line philly
november 26th and 27th right around eat
your turkey come see me
wawa go eagles cheesesteaks the irvine
improv
december 2nd then you can see me at cap
city comedy club in austin texas
december 9th through 11th you can see me
in new jersey at bananas comedy club
december 16th through 18th go to
andyletterman.com check out all the
dates there's a bunch of them it's going
to be really fun
[Music]
how have you not even had a reaction to
my bald cap literally what the [ __ ]
what the disgusting
am i looking at right i'm a priest of
course a jew would say that
this is really getting very it's a it's
a this is a
a religion war
let's go and why
i'm your pupils are shine
and why is kalila
just dressed
out of ten i've had this in my closet
for years guys it's actually the most
beautiful thing i've ever seen in my
life i'm mesmerized
and you forgot to draw my tits in i know
but i don't know if mine are drawn
enough to to counter this wig and you
have deodorant stains all over it
[Applause]
right now okay
does it even show on camera
what the wig
fryer
i'm hot fire truck i'm fryer um
[ __ ]
okay should we say what's going on i'm
fired tuck my dick that actually is very
cute is it really yeah it's very cute
unzip it a little let it get some cleave
there we go
oh it has a little tail so i was told
that the theme was a sexy halloween
costume but based on your child
something you dressed up as when you
were younger correct the fact that
nobody got you booty shorts in a johnny
rocket outfit makes me so upset
but i was always dressed as a dalmatian
when i was little because my favorite
movie was under one domination you were
also a legitimate dalmatian called jacob
right that's right i was i did think i
was a dog for a brief period of time and
this is actually surprisingly the
funniest part i don't know really boot
cuts
yesterday
my favorite dalmatian was i was pongo
you know what i don't know the
dalmatians that's where it's from pongo
because we had a foster that bobby named
pongo
and i just thought he just pulled it out
of nowhere i don't remember that maybe
he could name him
ago now it was pongo and perdita where
the mom and dad died
wait did you watch the the
the live-action one yes and did you like
it i did like it i've always had the
same thing like whenever someone remakes
something i'm just appreciative that i
get to experience my favorite thing in
another way i don't get like hatery
about it i surprisingly did get hatery
about beauty and obese and selena
i saw beauty the beauty and the beast
want except that i was really
what you just start talking like you've
seen a lot of movies
you're like i'm appreciative i'm not
hatery when they come up with the one
movie i've ever seen in my life
and then you haven't seen beauty and the
beast one of the most popular i know
know them with the re-live
[Music]
yeah i mean it was okay i still enjoyed
myself because i love all the songs i
know every word to every song hermione
was she wasn't it right that's right she
wasn't belle i'm sorry hermione you got
a character that was very popular i'll
never from a quiet village every day
little town full of little people
waking up
[Music]
the same old bread and rolls to sell
every morning just to see since the
morning that we came to the sport
provincial town good morning belle good
morning good morning
good morning yeah good morning okay
let's stop because i think this will
help this is not good for copyright
reasons on youtube oh that's right okay
so we should probably explain our
costumes unless they're pretty
self-explanatory i think annie needs a i
need a full head to toe i had a [ __ ]
staff and i'm really mad i had a stab
i'm really relieved oh and you would
have poked left and right with us now
i have questions i'll just let you take
the floor
what are you i was friar tuck in third
grade okay and so now i'm fire tucked
now but i'm
i'm sexy foreign friar and who's friar
tuck friar tuck is the priest in
robin hood why did you dress as that in
third grade i don't know i don't know
and i'm my mother's only daughter i
think she would have been like
like steered me in a different direction
she died as she brown and wrapped me in
it and i remember they only the only
friar tuck wig they had was was gray so
i was like an elderly firetruck makes
sense every mom's favorite movie at that
time was robin hood because of
kevin costner oh really and then the
bryan adams song to match the you know
in the soundtrack what's up
everything i do
i do it for you this is a musical
episode this is the musical episode guys
anything to distract from my wig
i feel like i i you know i i'm not like
the most vain person but it is hard to
be in a bald cap i look respectful in
public
when george said that i had to dress
like a hot version of an old costume
um
i really did consider this because i
told you guys that i was osama bin laden
like right after
you were and i just could not
i could not figure out a hot osama bin
laden i think he's always out because
he's always hot
you know it's never not been hot no
comment
osama zadie laden
oh my god it doesn't so there is a sexy
osama bin laden costume out there wow
that's disturbing will you look up sexy
friar tuck and see if i'm there i'm the
first one
i could have just cut out some sheets
shown my titties
but you are
wait it's like carlos's hair
oh my god it's carlos's hair he's been a
priest this whole time okay wait so
i chose selinas basically because um i
don't know if you guys know but deep
down inside
and this is no offense to the latino
community you are a latinx person i i
feel it like if you were to say like i
know i'm asian geographically
but
i'm flattened next
i feel very very connected to the
community i know at least like 15 selena
songs that's huge so i um therefore i'm
here to represent kinsey you look like
someone
my best friend christina's cuban i was
like
one of the dancers how fun was it it was
awesome were you wearing the same outfit
as
it's christina or right now
did you did she have it in a hall it was
in a beautiful banquet hall she wore a
dress that looked like a wedding dress
we were all like pink it looked like
bridesmaids even though we were 15. it
was very weird
um one of our cousins was super hot
jorge
oh my god perfect i made it for a hot
cousin
my friend melissa's quinceanera
um i
made out with at least three of her
mustached uncles what
oh my god is that true i just tongue
them down just hard went to them they
were like no you're a kid well no you
dance right
we danced too and then we
were dancing and they take the lead
and you know what i uh yeah and you made
out with uncles
actually there was a girl yeah but there
i had spanish but she had uncles that
were in their 20s like like older like
in their late 20s but i did have a
friend in high school that was totally
hooking up with one of our friends
uncles
drama
[Laughter]
or his dad when you were in high school
what's the oldest guy you um hooked up
with i when i was a freshman i like
briefly dated a senior like my very
beginning citizen
[Laughter]
but i didn't really i stayed within high
school for all of high school you think
you're ready and then you go home crying
is what it is like you talking about
when i had to retell this story to a
friend yesterday
what is going on i met this guy on like
uh the party line because i didn't have
like
yeah so we would just call and it's kind
of like swiping if you didn't like who
you were talking to you would press a
number and it would move on to wait is
this a real thing yeah
i never called them how much do they
cost
it was free the party lines were free
the party lines were free and so i met
this guy he went to cal state northridge
his name was brian and he said he was a
calvin klein model
and so he picked me up he lived all the
way in the i lived in pasadena he lived
like 40 minutes away here in the valley
he took me out to claim jumper i was 16
years old he wasn't he lived in the
dorms for some reason but he looked like
he was 30. you don't know claim jumper
it's like a chain restaurant yeah is it
did you work
no but i've been
it's fine
and then um he wouldn't give me a ride
home until like
he
[ __ ] me like brutally wait what
excuse me
it was really sad i had to recount the
story and i didn't think it hurt me
until i had to retell it again not it's
hurting me too not to hurt you more but
can you tell us more details yeah tell
us the brutal part
okay so after claim jumper i was like
okay like maybe we'll just do this and
we'll make out and even i was even open
to sex but the way that he had sex with
me was so like i wanna just beat this
girl up and then i was like after sex i
was like can you take me home now
and he was like no just sleep here and
the reason that he wanted me to sleep
there was because he wanted to wait a
couple hours
[ __ ] me again
brutally and then send me home crying
like i've never had i've never had
someone just
like terrorize me like that it was so
rough and so painful and there was no
it feels like a confession what do you
mean five hail marys
terrorized like that's where i'm
starting to be like this there was no it
was the story has always been bad
you're poking at details she's been
poked okay enough yeah it was really
rough i remember bleeding a lot i
remember just like just
it was horrible welcome to the halloween
episode guys vaginal bleeding included
yeah so this should say trigger warning
yeah but you know what giggle giggles
were you under 18. i was under 18. and
his name was brian and is he was over 18
oh he was probably 30 living in a dorm
somewhere in california northridge
statutory rape yes yeah for sure
welcome to trash tuesday and this is the
very beginning of this episode we have
not been through much yet
i i have um
one of me one i know mine is not going
to one-up you i'm so sorry but it you
know why
this is so why am i doing this because
you weren't as hot as her i know i'm not
a small people she was she was a model
oh i was i was and i i wasn't even
saying that i was a mall model i was a
big ugly swimmer
that's i'm just thank you so much for
acknowledging this it's getting so
awkward
when you stroll in you kind of put your
tits out a little that's what i'm saying
i know i'm not this one here so i say
that from that place you were not as hot
as her no i unless people raped you
because of it
thank you and again i'm because i do you
know what every time i have been like
i'm not even gonna lie you said that's
such a good point
because we need to reclaim our
molestations okay we actually were hot
so no i just want to clarify something
for you because you know she's like i
was raped and we're like what no it's
obvious she was hot we don't understand
because we were ugly i know it's like
when you do get when you do get less
nobody look
no when you look identical to the middle
hanson brother who i will tell is the
hottest handsome brother but he is a
young boy
and someone jizzes on you you go what
are you into
how was i was the one
my okay my rape story is not that good
obviously as the ugliest of the rape
um so i i was i kind of got up one
morning i was like i brushed my ugly
teeth and um no i went i was with my
friend we went to her uh
her i don't know how she was friends
with this guy but he was a grown man
that we were friends now isn't that
always definitely going to rape us like
why is it grown manny it's like
we were 13 or 14
which by the way you think you're you're
old then if you look back pictures of
you even if you are a mature one it
means you look fifteen no you're
absolutely
sure for 14 you look 15 years old all
this time when i made out with older
uncles i was like oh i look old they
must know i look old but when i look
back at pictures i'm like that's not no
we were so dude when i saw that video of
me at 18 speaking
i literally what video
the the sexy yeah where i was 18
but me 18 i look like a talking baby i
look like like a talking baby now i'm
acting like a baby
activity is it's
criminal
dave should be in [ __ ] prison i'm 33
just but it's so weird it's weird i told
you i hold your hand when you cross the
street i like forget i know and i don't
stop you dude i'm like
wait okay so you were telling a sex
story i said why did you turn into a sex
[ __ ]
you asked for it yeah and my my tie dyed
over my oversized tie dyed shirt with
the goofy picture
not anywhere else
i wasn't sexy yet so my friend was like
this guy's gonna buy his beer let's go
to his house and she made me go up to
his daughter's house room and make out
with him
he was like 40. in his daughter's and i
was 13 on his daughter's little bed wait
annie what
that was my story
it's did you say it's worse
i feel like it's a little creepier
because i think it's worse i think it's
worse too
because there's so there was coercion on
a different side my friend did it my
friend made me do it yeah that's bad
wait i'm not friends with her anymore
you know what [ __ ] i'm never letting
you do my hair she's a hairdresser now
i'm never letting you do my hair
actually she did my hands did she say
why actually you know what it's creepy
like that this [ __ ] year old man was
like get that little one to make out
that's
yeah recruiting he was using
her to recruit you in he probably banged
her what did you do you guys just made
out yeah it sucked i was so i hated it
why he was just ugly and i just didn't
like it and you did it for beer
i just did it because i didn't feel like
i had another option look and when it
comes to ugly that's never the issue for
me i've i
[ __ ] two boys one was named froggy
another one was named guac like they
called him guacamole
that that was he did because he called
him guacamole
oh my god look at her stoner laughs
are you high right now [ __ ] no but i
love a good chipotle joke
i took a mad dog 2020 to the dome
and somehow
do you remember that yeah i think that's
what that guy was buying me
delilah
tells us just now she hooked up with a
guy named guac and honestly you're
you've been let go from the show you're
gotta go you are we're gonna continue to
use the studio though thank you and if
bobby could make a cameo every other
that'd be great thank you god
after this episode i'm gonna need
some better help
you're not the only one
listen to your guys
if you've been tuning in at all at all
you know
that i've i have a long list of things
that have hindered my life
thankfully though
there's better help
dude you guys have to check out
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday betterhelp will assist
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient you can start
communicating in just under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online you are never gonna
regret actually getting help
it there's like i don't think this
podcast would still be on the air if we
didn't all use better health correct
they have licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in
depression stress anxiety anger family
conflicts all of it sleep trauma
anti-trauma podcast trauma trauma
mentioned on podcasts
trauma created
bipods for podcasts anything you share
is confidential it's convenient
professional affordable in fact so many
have been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states and listen we've all had like
crazy things happen everyone in life has
had something insane happen there's no
shame in it you just get a little help
if there's anything we know for sure now
mental health i just knocked this over
but mental health like we need mental
health help we can't just let it be
every you need help can't just be
smacking those microphones around
you guys we want you to start living a
happier life today for real and as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
calm
trash tuesday wow
the malls are open
bummer and i don't want to walk them i
don't want to do them anymore you know
why
stitch fix stitch fix has spoiled me i
get my own stylist
my clothes get shipped to my door i get
to return what i don't like
and it's that simple literally like
living like a queen
we're introducing stitch fix freestyle a
shop that is built just for you so
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your your style your likes and your
lifestyle whether you're looking for a
brand that you love or to try a new one
at stitch fix freestyle you can shop a
range of over
over a thousand brands that are
personalized to your size and fit which
makes shopping so much smoother of an
experience especially when like your
body's toddler but your face is like a
grown up yes it's curated for any
whoever you are with styles from
workouts to work wear for lounging
around the house or for a night out on
the town stitch fix freestyle has closed
for any occasion plus there's no
subscription required and they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges get
started today by filling out your style
quiz at stitchfix.com
tuesday that's stitchfix.com
tuesday to try stitch fix freestyle so
good stitch stitchfix.com
tuesday so much fun
okay what is this wait what george wait
what are we doing you have a sharpie so
draw the trash tuesday girls on your
pumpkin including yourself and the two
others here
[ __ ]
okay wait shut up george what are we
doing
drawing each other one person probably
we just choose one person to draw this
is so dumb we suck at drawing
george it's gonna be ugly as [ __ ] and
he's the only one that can draw this is
this is the segment
you know what i'm gonna give it a shot
wait i'm gonna be like why how frenemies
got cancelled was because trisha was
like called the segment bad and that's
like what i'm doing right now i'm like
the producer's stuck here
you hear that george
pete
here goes i'm drawing after first okay i
am a little high
don't tell
don't tell annie though it's just a tiny
bit
i just wanted to be loose
do not tell any i don't want her to know
because she's obsessed with it she keeps
bringing it up and asking me do not
[ __ ] tell her i'm drawing esther in
that outfit
are you drawing me being raped is annie
taking this [ __ ]
i think so
oh no oh no we have a costume change
excuse me
i'm sexy kenny g
but i put the thing on and i think i'm
just michelle wolf
now i have to change my drawings
i was in my wig
and you're supposed to draw us over
drawing each other
and in in the costumes okay okay i'm
done with mine don't look please do not
look over here i don't no no no
i won't
okay i have a really sad story oh good
it will fit the theme of the podcast
okay let's go full saddle okay my first
year of college i was like you know what
like i'm just [ __ ] i'm gonna go get
free candy and i'm gonna go trick or
treat and i went by myself and i just
dressed really warm and i had no costume
and like all the houses they were like
what like they didn't understand what i
was doing
[Laughter]
and it was so humiliating but i didn't
even give up like i just kept doing it
you guys are strong house after house
was like
what like you're an adult and you're not
in a costume
okay i guess we'll give you candy
it was really it was really dark i don't
like when people question it's like i'm
here yeah that's why the candy's there
give it to me that's what i thought it
was like this is just a formality the
costume is a formality by the way great
uh
great podcasting activity three
people sitting silently for 10 minutes
drawing i didn't say you had to be quiet
but listen it's like you know you go
through a couple rape stories a relapse
yeah you need to kind of you need to
draw on a pumpkin when that happens guys
you need more than just a banana break
i would take my banana early
[Music]
do you have do you guys have um dreams
of being like in a feeder relationship
have i asked you this um no
you don't esther no why is esther taking
a banana break ahead i thought we all
were you're the only one with a banana
who hates bananas isn't it crazy that
esther no longer hates bananas and was
just faking it oh can i have one
to my suspicions
you know i only like to eat
a worm sucker
what's in
you're new you're a new girl it's a
[ __ ] scorpion
you want the ants do you want a worm
oh no
pick your poison wow malatal syrup
here's the ingredients malatol syrup
scorpion
just the word scorpion
it's horrible
oh my god annie you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a stupid [ __ ]
i just draw what i see you know did you
put horns on her oh i made you so ugly i
didn't mean to i'm sorry you know what
you're not gonna like your i was trying
to make you feel you on this pumpkin
either annie annie
i it looks like you draw stevie weeby
your face looks so bad in this i'm so
sorry oh my god
why does it say esther first class on
the board
here's what the [ __ ] i'll say about that
i have a fear because we've all got
hawaii is official we're all going there
well i need to book my ticket you
haven't booked mine either
what
you guys i sent you that itinerary last
week can you resend it you sent it i
don't know yesterday by the way or two
days ago and also i am about to hit the
highest status in my thing so i have to
fly today before i can get my ticket
here
i have a i have this fear
that you're gonna go by yourself esther
is a bobby and that she's going to leave
us an economy and upgrade herself to
first class and he literally wants to do
that already told me last night she's
going to do it
so you both you [ __ ] are going to
leave me
in extra comfort
you're have status on hawaiian airlines
i am not going to spend my money like
that you know what i would never pay for
a first class ticket especially at a
time where i'm flying with people i know
because that makes it first class if
you're with people
you know no making first class and
watching your friends walk by you to the
back is
that's what bobby says he says it's a
pretty good feeling
no no no i usually i i made a um
i made a role to only fly first class
well dave said that you left him in
economy i had i had status on alaska
airlines it was not i didn't ever
upgrade you didn't ask for it well i
guess i checked a box that said i would
be down
but i did get upgraded on our way to
mexico and i was in first and he was but
he's that's funny to leave dave back
there he sits on the plane the moment he
sits down he falls asleep okay i have a
question follow-up question is um does
he have resentments no he doesn't care
he but i do think he plays those a bit
like that it's funny bobby has done that
to me what do you mean he's left me for
first class and how do you feel i hated
him for two days why be proud of him
cause i was like i needed his shoulder
to knock out on did he invite you he
didn't invite me wait are you serious
and then he blamed his manager for he's
like abby booked this so i'm
and i called abby i was like did you do
this she's like no i didn't he must have
upgraded himself
that's so funny to be a liar oh we
fought we've we scrapped all right this
is kalyala i give her her shoulders that
she loves oh thank you big and buff
her big shoulders pretty
there's myself
abs with abs absolutely hot just
gorgeous
great hair extremely masculine and then
these have been very accurate you guys
look like stevie weeby there and then
here's esther
embassy there's esther
okay so you think i'm stewie from family
guy i think that your head is fatter
than your body
that's what i think i think you've got a
smoking body and i think we got to work
on that face i'm just kidding but
you have you have a great um head to
body ratio you don't have like no you've
got a hot body you're secretly hungry i
have i have a big big big face but
filipino no you're really hot but it's
you know we like you not knowing it yeah
last night annie said we have to keep
kelila down
and not knowing that how hot she is
she's going to run away
which i'm pretty sure she said the first
day we did the show anyways
so hello
what's your your it's your big reveal
okay so i'm not really an artist i feel
like you're now on this one i have a
feeling
i've been watching just want to be
careful and i've been watching a lot of
jeopardy
what is old rotten sperm
and i weighed your 10 of the ip of the
podcast
this felt fitting to me because
i did it in the form of a question and
we are all old rotten sperm we all were
made from old men
and i just thought was on my walk
yesterday i was thinking we haven't
talked about that in a while we haven't
so here's a reminder i have a question
um are you watching mayan bialik yes
you're down are you liking it yeah i
think she's actually great because she's
it's just fine like you just want
someone who's just fine and that's what
she's but also she's got like the
credentials she's like a whiz she's like
or did she just play one on that show no
no she she went to like harvard like she
went she's like a real like neuro
she's like eliza i've met her before
it's been really it's it's shocking to
me
blossom i just been in my life a long
time i was like i don't care
how smart the host is just are they like
a good simple host and are they getting
us to where we need to go well that's
great that means you can like me on this
podcast
here we go
here's mine oh my god i love it oh i
love you
you got esther's arm to like burst
perfect well so why is one of my legs a
stick and the other is like a cankle did
you give me a penis
yeah what's going on why does she have a
boob oh you made us all hot annie looks
pretty good yeah it's pretty gorgeous
you forgot my tits
well they're in oh she didn't forget her
own tits
cute
are we um um judging this george who's
the dr oh god oh no
you guys this is binding you didn't know
that
no this is a fun activity no judgment
over here we're not gonna have the man
on the show judge everybody oh george oh
really the guy that wanted part of our
only fans money
[Laughter]
come on girls spread the cheeks we got
money to make spread we got members i
gotta see those [ __ ]
esther you better eat that [ __ ] like
you promised oh that's what we should
have members only jackets yes we're only
fan subscribers yeah but what are they
gonna i don't know what that means but
yes
i want to have like pink lady jackets i
want letterman jackets yes yes
george get to work i've heard five
things
also can you just make something happen
we want one piece of merch by next week
for [ __ ] sake we're we got teslas we
got first class
we have tesla's defense i'm staying in
um extra comfort economy we got teslas
to lease
i'm going in the stowaway
can you can i be your carry-on i don't
want to pay for my flight wait i want to
say that you're my dog can we please try
to get my emotional support dog let's
just attempt it let's just see what they
do i will i will we'll say they're kink
shaming i will play the character
we gotta find a sherpa bag to shove you
in can i just tell you i will 100
pretend to be i i listen i pledge right
now that i will say this is my dog and
we will ride this bit until they almost
and i pledge that i will not be on the
same flight
that's my pledge we're gonna be flying
private [ __ ] enjoy your [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god and he's bought a
plane i bought a plane you guys george
george can we sell some merch
wait wait guys my tesla plane is i have
a pro this is what i said when i said i
had a topic i have a proposition for you
i was thinking last night after i saw
you this morning
i think i should be your business
manager
and i want to know what you think i
would be terrible because you would be
you were coming to be like you're
spending like you would literally
i think i should be your business
manager i think the audience should vote
i want to tell you that she okay wait
she he sorry
i don't want to miss gender
um
he was like last night he was like
you spend too much money and then also
he goes i need a popcorn machine too
send me the link
so this would be a business manager
that's telling me like like by like
getting a tesla is a bad idea but
definitely get the popcorn machine i
don't know i think this is what i look
for in a business manager keep spending
baby
[Laughter]
thanks thanks buddy i just want
something to go you're doing great keep
doing it what do they do for you that i
can't do
i'm just really this is a genuinely you
know what they do they don't you know
what they do they don't annoy me
i'm never annoyed by them esther where
would you take let's say annie he's like
here's my savings account i want to
invest it where would you put it i
here's the thing because i don't even i
think the business manager just like
pays the bills organizes
and tells you your budget and i think i
think i would be i i'm not saying i want
the job i'm not saying i really are are
you going to buy books
i think i would be a good business
manager let's role play hey i'm at this
halloween shop i just bought my friar
tuck outfit but there's this other
outfit i really want it kind of looks
like michelle
it's 400 should i get it it's for one
episode
but it's so funny four hundred dollars
for spots a while for the left why are
you calling me for an individual
purchase like that's just this is
already too much and you owe me more so
you're now you're quitting
you're resigning
first role play
i would say um
okay wow 400 for an episode i'd think
that that might be
like
so you think i should charge the other
girls for it because they're kind of a
part of this wait uh maybe you got it
[Laughter]
all right here's another let me think of
a real purchase i hit my bonuses this
weekend okay
made a lot of money i would
i really want to buy my boyfriend a 300
jacket i would say like
just because you just made bonuses or
you just made money that doesn't mean
you have to buy something every time
like i'd actually as your business
manager i'd like to get you out of this
well you know what you don't know who
you're working because you're working
with annie bonus letterman she lives a
different life than you
i bought that test laughter bonus i go
wild oh my god i go wild
oh my god and these bonuses when i talk
about these bonuses they're low why do i
feel
why do i i'm not i'm not
listen you'd see these numbers you go
i just i can't help but feel like one
day i see myself i'm like 65 and i'm
singing in a jazz club in vegas to pay
off annie's gambling deaths
like i feel like that's where we're
headed oh my god i remind you of your
father is that what it is
no because he doesn't spend
he saves to gamble
kind of
some would argue that i gotta say
gambling's fun i don't know what else to
say other than murray
i support you
actually i would i'm looking i would
have a i need a private eye if he does
go to vegas i think i'm gonna hire
carlos to just go and watch him from
afar is he going to vase it's this was
the whole controversy i think he is now
not going but when he was going to go i
was going to have carlos on it like
secretly just go because he's my dad's
78 like yeah he needs like a
a handler yeah carlos he needs a carlos
we all need a car i got i got um
followed to vegas you did buy an
ex-boyfriend
that's how good that last slip
he caught me slipping
oh he was your boyfriend at the time he
wasn't really we weren't exclusive but
um i did go to vegas and um he had
someone
follow me to like the pool party take
pictures of me like hooking up with
someone else we weren't even was it a
girl
no it was a guy but um yeah um how would
you feel if someone followed yes or
would you feel violent oh my god it was
deserved i would love it be like great
like watch over this is what she has to
say to me
because of what she is
it's like the political statement it's
like no we are here at esther
incorporated we stand by we would love
to be watched as well
this is all which is like scientology
you're scientology everything is normal
this girl has more cameras out on people
than scientology literally
that's a fact no i'm a spy i'm
absolutely one of my big fights with
esther she was one of my location no
yeah i was like [ __ ] i would never give
up my location
i really thought you would give me your
location i mean you did ten years of
ground work on that and yeah never will
you get it yeah now you know and that's
hard
and you know what location do you have
dave
my friend nick
my sister
nick yeah
the nick i know yeah just to have it
i saw him the other day by the way where
i was on abba kinney and i was like
oh that's so funny
great do you have george's location i
wish that would actually be the perfect
location to have like george where the
[ __ ] are you i have my mom i have carlos
i have my dad i have john i have my
friend kristen my friend lina i have my
second phone and then my childhood best
friend christina give jenna you have
your sex no i should no jenna jenna no
don't do it jenna why i would love yours
kalila but we can don't do it and we
also know where klyla is here always
it's true she's not here we just put a
location on her mom we'll know where she
is
no we should put something on our car oh
let's put a bomb
no
it's like the pelican brief
you guys know that 30 million women are
impacted by weakened or thinning hair
and if you're among them you are not
alone and there's a solution that we all
trust that can deliver results and i'm
not kidding you when i say when i turned
30 i couldn't believe how much hair i
actually lost i don't know if it was a
hormonal shift what happened but it was
like oh i'm never gonna grow long hair
again
but with nutrifoal i'm not kidding you
guys her pubes are full so full and so
beautiful
they're so long and straight
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
neutrophil offers two targeted formulas
for women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness with
less shedding through all stages of life
honestly though this is how i know
they're legit is because they don't just
say like instant results they're like no
this is going it takes time
you will get healthy hair growth over
time you'll begin to experience thicker
stronger and faster growing hair in
three to six months and i think that's
key is patience yeah like anything it
actually works right scam any pill
that's gonna promise overnight results
is a scam this isn't it in a clinical
study 86 of women reported improved hair
growth after six months more than
fifteen hundred top doctors recommend
neutrophil as an effective and high
quality solution for healthier hair you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month's
subscription this is our best offer
anywhere we made sure of it and it's
only available to us customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get fifteen dollars off at
nutrafl.com spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash
trash
okay don't let the stress of daily life
weigh on your body whether you're an
elite athlete like kalila or someone
like me and annie just trying to make it
through the day tension-free a thera-gun
can help that's not esther exaggerating
by the way
it cuts my recovery time in half when i
have really hard like training workouts
or
when i do my fancy um
soul cycling she's a soul cycler baby i
mean it really is like it's gets the
lactic acid broken up it's great
okay here's the deal theragun is the
handheld per cut percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest muscle
tension using a scientifically
calibrated combo of depth speed and
power and it's as quiet as an electric
toothbrush how quiet this is that's so
awesome i can't believe that this wasn't
around like my whole life like it's just
such a it's like a problem solver you
know what i make bobby do
at night i make him just
go
i just make him theragan my hamstrings
when they're really tight and i'm
telling you guys it's heaven
a few things feel better than that here
the gen 4 theragon doesn't just feel
good it gets to the source of the pain
by releasing tension using theragon's
signature percussive therapy which goes
60 deeper than vibration alone whether
you want to treat your muscle tension
from working out an injury or just the
stresses of everyday life there's no
substitute for the theragan gen 4 i like
so good i like that she's
working out
injury and then stresses of everyday
life
the oled screen and design make you feel
like you're holding something from the
future look at esther i know it really
is so good
just go to their site and check it out
the theragun app learns from your
behaviors and suggests guided routines
try theragun for 30 days starting at
only
199. go to therabody.com
trash tuesday right now and get your gen
4 theragun today that's therabody.com
trash tuesday
therabody.com trash tuesday
esther didn't you send me an article
about um
how
there was like an article written about
um we have it wrong as a society and
that we should and friendship should
mean more than like romantic
relationships oh my god we should live
with our friends we should live with our
friends and that we shouldn't like hyper
focus on finding the one the partner
when we have it's like yeah do you know
what that sounds like
it sounds like a lesbian who's dating a
man going we should hang out with our
girlfriends more
we should put more emphasis on the women
in our lives
it's just like i
i handed it to you
oh there it is
what if friendship not marriage was at
the center of life our boyfriends our
significant others our husbands are
supposed to be number one our worlds are
backwards i think it's true
said the saddest girl in the whole world
no because the more that i share and
focus on my friendships the better it is
with my partner because i'm not like
going to him for everything yeah like
like sex and being hot like a hot girl
you can't be he can't be like your
one-stop shop friend no he doesn't have
a [ __ ] of course not
and i used to think that the partner is
everything and now i'm like no
the friends are everything come here
girls
who's your oldest friend of all time
your best best best friend christina
does dave outrank her no
in some ways drowning they're drowning
sophie's choice
there's no way that there's a scenario
where they're there's definitely a snake
because you can't save them
yeah i don't swim
this scenario is i'm drowning it's who
saves you
and it would be christina because she
actually
christina would save me way faster than
dave wood well david rank your favorites
on your phone that's how you can tell i
don't have favorites i don't have
favorites either no i used but i call
you guys i call todd i call
my sister outranks everyone in my life
really she'll probably outrank my kids
that's cool
i think so like i i don't think i could
love a being more than i love my sister
what's your age i'm so jealous
i'm so jealous of that that sounds
awesome that's how i feel about my 20
never picks up though
you never mind i haven't spoken them in
three years my twin's the most uh called
yet never picked up
[Laughter]
i don't know who is above
who but i know that like there's
definitely you know what
when someone that i was friends with
passed away it changed my perspective on
everything because i just realized oh
people
are the most important thing in your
life period like what did you think was
important before popcorn
[Music]
like i gotta stop eating so much popcorn
there are people out there
so there are these people out there
listen
so i'm gonna put these kernels down
i really like my friendships i'm like
upset like i love them so much but i
right now i talked to carlos and john
the most oh god don't miss it
no that was they're fun yeah oh i guess
i would pick todd over everyone yeah i
love my todd
but then you think about it it's like
you have broken up with boyfriends
before yes that's what you never see
them again and your friends are like
yeah and my friends aren't going
anywhere we're not breaking up most of
my my friends i've broken up with we get
back together too it's not like unless
they were just like not good and they
weren't my people to begin with well
that's what i'm saying it's like
we're you know we're so primed to
believe that
this is your person and that you're
supposed to be your best friend and your
you know this life that you're supposed
to then you force yourselves to live
together and do this and it's like
yeah i i do kind of agree that i would
be so happy to live with my sister and
my best friend jess for the rest of my
life yeah
and i'll fight
and we'd have squabbles but it doesn't
matter like we were not ever leaving
each other because it's determined yeah
like we're best friends forever did you
would your friend jess ever side with
your sister over you and then she has
yeah yeah we go back and forth a lot
it's a swapsies yeah it's a swapsies
between three of us and my sister and i
uh dynamic of three is fun three is the
greatest three is so much fun yeah i
love this i love a trio mm-hmm threesome
because when you want you can just kind
of sit back and go
yeah one of you can be late
but i've sat back but i've never stopped
i don't have one person that is above
dave but i would say like
dave friendship
family like all are equals
in the same concentric circle who do you
like better your mom or your dad i like
them both they're you need both the way
it's the dynamic paused and already knew
the answer but decided not to say it was
so good no it's the dynamics between
them that is the toxic
comedy that
keeps on
delivering
i i would say to todd when we first got
randy
are you talking i'd be like todd i love
you the most i've ever in the whole
world to go even randy
i'm like oh i guess i gotta pick you
cause randy's a dog is going to die
pretty soon i pick my dogs over some
people we say that all the time was like
i love you so much but i love donut more
it's so funny you know what i like to do
when someone goes i love you so much you
go why
oh yeah
but why
okay that's good the other day i taught
i was looking up into space where at
brunch and toggles what are you thinking
about and i was like
i'm thinking that i i'm sorry i'm so
glad you asked i was like i was hoping
someone would ask
about i love every single thing about
myself
and he started laughing i was like yeah
i was just thinking about like my thighs
like i kind of like my cellulite and
he's like i want to drink water out of
this and i was like chill it's not like
water levels cellulite todd
another guy lizzie cooperman came with
me to colorado i had so much fun in
denver by the way to anyone that came
out oh my god
have you been to comedy works in a while
not lately it's the most fun it's cool
it was crazy it was so fun do you stay
in the um the community
yeah i actually started painting again
because in the condos oh i remember that
yeah they have like they're that comedy
condo though it has like a creepy like
chain man
what are those called knights
yeah
that they don't even read to me as like
a scary thing but because they're taller
than you i can see thank you
no it's cool they got a lot of crazy
stuff in there
but i started painting and it was fun my
painting was good you want to see it
i've painted twice that's my third
painting i've ever done in my life
really yup
wait i have a question for you guys are
you guys coming to my birthday karaoke
extravaganza i wasn't invited yeah you
were esther
when is it it's next saturday in
koreatown it's just karaoke in costume
though i literally was not invited
you weren't no i said i'm only going
investors
where was the invitation wait a second
no one no one has been invited except i
was here i was talking to pete and and
george and i invited everyone annie
if i did this every day i would get
really good at it
that's so good whoa
i was proud of myself i was like oh my
god i'm good you should be proud yeah
wait klyla can i come no
where is this okay we're going to do
you have to find us though can you buy
locations yes george can film we're
going to invite one of the people on
your that you have their location we're
not going to tell you which one you have
to go to all their locations try to find
us thank you a scavenger hunt
to get to my co-worker's birthday
costumes are optional since i know we
dressed up today but i gotta get another
costume i think i'm gonna go as a a dead
shaman to whitney's thing are you going
to witness thing yeah i'm out of town
you're such a liar i've never she goes
i'm out of time i am out of town i'm
going to be in the desert am i not out
of town on the twenty second in the
desert
way too much in the next couple i'm
always in the desert that this my
birthday week is i'm always in the
desert can we go to that part yeah
but that was a long no pause
i know that's definitely not a yeah
yes
it's my time to uh where do you go would
you go alone um no i usually go with my
family oh you don't oh yeah when you
guys just look at the cactus yeah we
just look at cacti joshua trees all day
shouldn't it be cacti as one and
cactuses is the rest yeah i think it's
like cactus is the other ones it's so
annoying yeah and the fact that octopus
is not octopi yeah it's just get with
the program right isn't it octopuses i
thought i heard it was octa [ __ ]
we haven't even had a banana break
but you didn't hear it has anyone seen
this uh let's do the banana break now
let's do the the non-ester i ate a
banana already [ __ ] i'm the only one
that didn't banana stupid [ __ ] on your
birthday week on the day of my repay
it's a raw pay
[Music]
did anyone see how esther did not flinch
one second while he fingered her vagina
try it again
what do i care it feels good you're it's
a woman's hands with nice nails
why would i stop that
women have soft hands would you be okay
being fingered by long nails that sounds
kind of fun
oh my god surprising
that's fun only on only fans but only
like if i'm like having bv or something
because it's itchy oh that's true i woke
up with an itchy badge today
is it just regular feminine the jinx or
like a full-on yeasty not a tasty
totally fine just i woke up like very
like
i couldn't like my headphones dropped in
a box like i don't even know where they
are
i was i couldn't walk i felt like bambi
you know first born
and um and then i like clinked and i
went oh my [ __ ] edges you know
we had
rape and we wasn't gonna be a full
episode until we had vaginal discharge
chat hmm george until kalila says it
ain't over until collila says da jinky
do you ever look at your underwear and
go maybe i am a squirter
i have never squirted in my life i
haven't i've fake squirted and like pedo
on somebody oh that's fun
oh my god esther if we ever hook up i'm
pissing all over you
if it ever comes down dude i'm going to
say
oh yeah i'm going to have you squirted
us sir
she's going to pull right on your shoes
[Laughter]
no i have not been peed on is that no no
a squirted oh uh i like how you answer
this like this hasn't been asked like 75
times in this podcast no i have not
squirted yeah me neither i'm not a
squirter me neither but i had a guy try
a bunch and it was like me too i can
sort of feel it like yeah like it does
feel like you're peeing like you just
have to pee i'm like i don't want to
though yeah you're not trying to happen
george are you um do you like your
[ __ ] oh my god you're a squirter
[Laughter]
vanilla
he's such a puss puss it's because his
dad's in town he can't talk like this
is papa's near is your dad jinji
i love his dad dark hair
you're the freak
i'm blonde
i mean come on bond
blonde is ginger if you really look at
it um would you go um there's this in um
this is old um it used to be uh
i guess an insane asylum i hate using it
i love this um in pasadena and um do you
want to go ghost hunting yes are you
[ __ ] kidding of course i do what what
are the gadgets that you would use tell
me what you would bring to this i don't
have gadgets because i'm not like in the
men in black but i
thought
i had a nebulizer from burger king
halloween tour
what men and black was aliens that's
right thank you
thank you so much
[Laughter]
um i would just like i loved 100
dalmatians the cats are so cute in it
i love those cats
i'm
getting almost upset
at you even bringing up us going ghost
hunting because like then let's [ __ ]
actually go do that like literally tell
me when and where i will get i will
dress in all black i will get warm we
will go at night
do you have a third eye do you have a
portal you think it's her cervix i like
when you touch me it's weird that she's
not ticklish oh my gosh his skin sucks
that is
that's going to tell you that last night
i literally that was the thing i wanted
to tell you was have you checked out the
skim socks
because they're pretty good
they did come out with that that purple
color today i ordered it this morning we
got this one yeah
don't they have the new neon ones too
yeah there's a ultra
ultra violet
i just feel as though you're not a
susceptible person to um have um a being
jump into your being and i think that's
why you have no fear she's been
possessed by an elderly woman
you're unpossessable thank you
and i think that's why you have no fear
i think that i have a portal i think
that they they would sense it and they
would jump into me really
oh my god we're gonna have to like stop
a ghost raping
it's like jesus guys we get it we're not
hot all right
she's the hot one
it's so annoying she gets raped so much
more than us if this is a i just want to
know is this real because i will go go
something with you guys let's just let's
go let's and let's make let's make a we
should do a video
these guys film it
let's bring this to the to the fans
let's bring it to the fans a little
bottle of holy water right mm-hmm you're
going to bring that um fryer tux cross
bring the wig too i'm going to bring my
full catholic church i'll tell you this
i'm definitely not bringing religious
stuff oh i am what religious stuff do
you have i'm not a torah no but i'm not
there's no i don't need anything
religious you're gonna answer you're
like
i'm gonna bring snacks i'm going to
bring
my myself and my spirits
i've never met a ghost okay all the
spirits that come to me are reels
look at this scary
esther's shore he's talking about uh
oh my god
george is bringing up his own content
his own content from 2015 do not even
rick glassman wouldn't unfollow him by
the way rick clossman's gonna clip you
sang rick glassman yes that's so funny
oh wait rick dm'd me and was like i'll
have you in my pockets but i have a list
of um
demands and i go my my number one demand
is i have to be able to read the demands
on air
holy [ __ ]
why don't we no let's have let's have
rick on this show when you're here i
have a birthday request i need you to
recreate rogan's ice bath but into a
freezer okay
into that freezer oh no i want to do an
ice let's oh my god let's recreate the
i'll just i'll do a nice bath on the
show i mean you know i won't on the show
we need to buy we need a we need a sauna
uh-huh and an ice bath put in here
and that comes out of your cut george
don't be a dick as long as i can keep
them afterwards
no they're going to be installed in here
um so you [ __ ] need to buy your
hawaii tickets [ __ ] um promise sign a
waiver let's go somewhere else let's go
to a different island sign a waiver that
you're not going to leave me for first
class no we'll send this [ __ ] she's
going to
no it's going to be esther first
and she's going to do it slyly no no no
she's like guys i didn't ask for this i
want to be with you guys i'm esther is
more codependent than she is i'm gonna
[ __ ] party on the plane with you guys
i will tell you something i have never
had more fun than i had on that plane
with us flying together i laughed so
hard i
we george you have to post these on
because you understand that when we're
on the plane it's going to be exactly
like when we're together but we're going
to have an audience it was so
the plane passengers are our audience
these chairs are our state do you know
when you laugh so hard that spit is like
coming out of it like you can't control
it it was like that the entire flight
esther was closing this woman was like
leaning into her seat and esther kept
closing the thing on her back like it
would stop
on her back
and then and then the lady was like look
and we'd have to like pretend like it
wasn't happening like crying laughing
we're going to be sitting at this lady
for the entire [ __ ] fight i'm going
to be that lady
i'm going to be that lady we have to get
our seats together how do we do that i
gave him where did the boys go where did
the boys go
stowage yeah still todd's gonna fly it
todd's a pilot no andy's gonna meet us
there on our private plane she goes like
this esther goes she's asking about the
problem and she like oh my god how do
you mate like was it hard to put
together i'm like it's so crazy you
think that i have any of these answers
she's like is it hard to make the
popcorn i'm like
20 batches of popcorn have been made in
my popcorn machine and not one has been
made by me
i do not think todd does everything
i'm so jealous that's the rules well
thank you guys for watching yet another
wonderfully
broken episode of trash tuesday and can
i just say if you want to support us
we'd love for you to like this video
subs make sure you're subscribed to our
channel go check out our clips channel
because we have these things we want
them to grow we're not just telling you
about
these horrible things for nothing for
free you're afraid
you got to pay for these rappe stories
but your support means a lot to us see
you guys bye guys
[Music]
you